foreign
has moved to a point where we can
actually rescue species that are going
extinct there are certain times when
intervention is Justified when there's
no other alternatives
we have the technology we have the will
let's bring these trees back
for Generations the American chestnut
dominated East Coast forests a tree
vital to both wildlife and humans prized
for its Bountiful nuts and straight
light rot resistant Lumber people used
to say Chestnut used to follow you from
the Cradle to the Grave because it was
made to make cradles and also coffins if
you hear the song around Christmas time
of chestnuts Rosemary Open Fire or the
song Sleigh Ride where they hear the
chestnuts going pop pop those are
American chestnuts
foreign Chestnut blight is totally a
man-made problem it happens when people
started importing Asian species of the
chestnut tree people were bringing them
in at the turn of the century because
they had desirable qualities for like
nut production and you know at the time
they didn't realize when they imported
these they also import all the microbes
on the tree and so when they brought
these trees over they brought over this
fungus called crife nectar parasitica
the Asian Chestnut trees could tolerate
that fungus but the American could not
light was found in a Bronx Zoo in 1904.
fast forward to 1950 4 billion trees
were dead from this disease
today there's just Sprouts the trees
like living in the understory of the
forest and it's re-sprouting and dying
back over and over again
the remaining American chestnut
population rarely survived to maturity
making the species functionally extinct
groups like The American chestnut
Foundation are looking for ways to bring
back the tree the American chestnut
Foundation was started in 1983 with this
idea that you could basically bring in
disease resistance from one variety of
plants into another through this process
called back cross breeding that was our
bread and butter since 1983 and that
worked sort of okay turned out after
years and years of breeding that it's
not quite that simple that it could
actually be resistance genes on every
single chromosome of the chestnut that
means 12 or more genes that are involved
that complication is very much they've
made great progress but so far they
probably only made about halfway to full
resistance in the 1990s members of the
New York chapter of the American
chestnut Foundation approached SUNY ESF
asking if there might be a way to use
genetic engineering to create a blight
tolerant tree
and we talked to him about it and said
well this could be done it's not a quick
fix it'd probably take at least 10 years
of course it's taken more than 30 years
to do it
the chestnut blight fungus secretes an
acid that kills the tree bark and
eventually the tree Itself by inserting
a gene from wheat scientists have found
a way to detoxify that acid creating a
blight resistant American chestnut tree
it's not perfect there is some damage
that still occurs but the tree does much
better is able to grow and reproduce and
flower we have tested it against
non-target organisms know that it's not
having any effect other than increasing
resistance to Chestnut blight if they
gain regulatory approval the American
chestnut will become the first
genetically engineered plant released
with the express purpose of spreading in
the wild we want to re-wild the American
chestnut so it can resume evolving on
its own forming it's a self-sustaining
population to achieve this goal
Regulators must Grant the transgenic
tree non-regulated status a process
still under review both in nature
conservancy and the environmental
defense fund have file public comments
supporting deregulation even the Sierra
Club a group with a history of opposing
GMOs has stated that in this case the
technique might prove an environmental
benefit however there remain a number of
Skeptics concerned about the
implications of releasing a tree
engineered in a lab into the wild a root
of all of the concern the opposition is
this idea of what's natural a lot of
people again like things like making
hybrids and stuff like that and that's
great those have been great trees but
you're making a lot of changes we have
two species Chinese Chestnut American
chestnut that are diverged in
evolutionary Time by 40 million years so
a lot of changes have occurred in that
time and when you're doing this breeding
you're bringing along a lot of traits
from Chinese Chestnut into the American
chestnut back you know genetic
background we are making smaller changes
to the tree therefore if you want
something that's more original if you
want something that's more World already
adapted to the the forest ecosystem and
genetic engineering is the way to go
we're inserting a single gene into the
genome and otherwise
the the rest of the genome is the same
as the wild American chestnut but the
creation of a blight resistant tree and
volunteers at the ready the dream of
restoring the American chestnut appears
to poised to become a reality but
regulatory obstacles remain basically
this tree is at the point where we're
ready to get it out to the public but
because we use the techniques of genetic
engineering we used to have another
hurdle to get over and that is the
regulatory review
we are working with three agencies the
USDA the EPA and the FDA all three
regulate it for different reasons
Regulators typically review GMOs from
private companies seeking to patent and
sell their Creations but the transgenic
American chestnut would be freely
released a difference that required a
fair amount of education on both sides
of the process we've actually started
going to The Regulators back in 2014
mainly because this is something very
new and we wanted to find out what
experiments they would want us to do
before we submitted our applications and
give us time to do that we want to make
sure we're not creating more problems so
there has to be some kind of evaluation
of these things but there's like a
double standard with breeding like we've
made huge changes with biotechnology
it's a smaller change but it's evaluated
under such scrutiny compared to just
doing stuff we do regularly with
breeding to me it should be like
breeding and biotech are evaluated in a
similar way the Regulatory Agencies plan
to announce decisions within the next
year both Powell and Westbrook are
cautiously optimistic I mean the fact
that the USDA has said that they're
going to issue decision in August 2023
as positive sometimes these decisions
like kind of get mired in the process
they'll not consider it or it'll just be
in review forever
and they said that they're going to
issue a decision so that's that's a
positive sign well after we get the
approvals we have a big party at first
but it'd be great because that's when we
actually start getting the trees out the
public and we're producing a lot of
trees so we can actually get some out
right away to the people who've been
waiting for these things for 30 years if
they succeed it could be the beginning
of a new chapter in environmental
restoration this can set an example for
other groups to be able to use
biotechnology for for restoration and
conservation and I think that option
Canon should be open this Chestnut
project is not a end product in and of
itself is that this is actually
developing a road map to restore other
tree species I think the chestnut is
kind of an example of an interventionist
approach we are participating in the
the future of our planet and that we
might have some capabilities and
responsibilities to correct some of the
problems that we created
[Music]